well I guess this proves there as many
nuts and the Academy as anywhere else
that people should accepting his Oscar
for One Flew of the Cuckoo's Nest in
1976 to present this year's award for
sound on film here is the appealing
young daughter and only when I laugh and
the young co-star of Blue Lagoon Kristy
McNichol and Christopher Atkins
too often we all take for granted the
tremendous contributions of Hollywood
sound engineers tonight we don't people
who realize how important sound really
is did not
that's achievement sound are Richard
Portman and David Ronnie four on Golden
Pond John K Wilkinson Robert W glass jr.
Robert m Thoreau well and Robin Gregory
for Outland
morning Richard Tyler and al overt
infants pennies from heaven nobody's
Steve Myers well Greg Lander maker Roy
Charmin for Raiders of the Lost Ark Rick
Dore was sick Tom twice nice on you
careful Reds
bill Varney
on this occasion last year I think I
said that it takes the creative talents
of a lot of people to create a
soundtrack of this magnitude and
certainly the same as the case this year
the team is almost the same and I think
well the Steve and Greg will agree with
me that we're the most fortunate sound
mixers in the world to be surrounded
with such talented sound people and
sound engineers a particular
acknowledgement tonight to our good
friend Ben bird and Richard Anderson
and their special achievement award they
received for the same motion picture our
thanks to all of the editorial staff the
engineers at the Samuel Goldwyn sound
facility especially our our right and
left a man Kevin O'Connell again and to
two of the best filmmakers in the world
George Lucas Steven Spielberg producers
frank marshall and howard kazanjian
thank you for your trust and faith and
letting us be part of this magnificent
adventure thank you thank you